c'est qu'elle était carrément espionner
ouais quand elle avait des rapports
sexuels si on a bien lu ce qu'on a lu
cette semaine
alors elle était en procès à l'époque
avec elle allait être en procès avec son
ancien manager sam lufti qui l'a accusée
au long du procès d'avoir fait ça pour
ne pas qu'on puisse s'apercevoir qu'elle
était sous amphètes sous amphétamines
regardez la garde de ses enfants pas ce
qui est en procès avec son aile et c est
ce que tout le monde ne sait pas c'est
qu'on peut trouver des traces
d'amphétamines de drogue et de plein
d'autres choses dans les cheveux
saoudite à l'abri vous tranquille c'est
pour ça j'ai fait un choix radical ya
longtemps vous achetez et elle en fait
elle l'a fait qu'on peut entendre et de
l'aider des traces de drogue jusqu'à un
an dans les cheveux et c'est pour ça
notamment que les cyclistes les
cyclistes sera entièrement exactement et
plus grands comptes qui sont morts comme
pantani qui est mort d'une overdose de
2,2 de stimulants bas il était
complètement rasée il sera sous les
jambes c'est trop de choses pour les
pansements mais au gran c'est parce
qu'on peut remonter par centime est ce
qu'on peut savoir si on allait de la
drogue dans le sang au moment m au
moment d choper ac le avec les cheveux
on remonte sur une période donnée comme
ça que même napoléon leur bon temps dans
l'eau en le dp rang pendant ses shows là
dessus qu'il avait au moins étaient
enterrés à il avait empoisonné au
cyanure ans parce qu'on est venus ici
allure dans ses cheveux et ses
aïeux des révélations absolument
incroyable sur sa sécurité à l'époque
était sous la tutelle de son papa et
avait alors il y aurait eu des caméras
même même dans sa chambre au moins elle
faisait des cra cra oui et c'est son
père qui écoutait en plus donc son père
écoutait sa propre fille faire crac-crac
c'était risqué ça lui étaient envoyés
vous imaginez alors à laver pourquoi
florian il a mille des caméras dans sa
chambre parce que ça faisait partie
enfin en tout cas selon lui sur la
société qu'il avait mandaté pour le
faire de la tutelle dont étaient
prisonnières britney spears pendant
toutes ces années et en gros son
téléphone tous ces coups de fil divers
et variés sont internet et sa maison
était flic et du début jusqu'à la fin et
il faut rappeler quand même que le père
qui n'a jamais suivi la carrière de
britney spears touché 130000 euros par
an + des royalties sur les sur sur les
disques continuer d'avancer l'argent
avec compte tenu des revenus de briser
panon fins et c'est pas une part
importante à la brasse et des dizaines
voire des centaines de millions de
dollars certes sauf qu'elle n'a jamais
demandé à être sous la tutelle
tu as d'ailleurs s'en est emparé pour
briser cette tutelle parce qu'il y avait
on va pas revenir sur toute l'histoire
mais tout ça a été à la limite de la
légalité est relativement scandaleux
c'est qu'elle était carrément espionner
ouais elle était je veux dire quand elle
avait des rapports sexuels si on a bien
lu ce qu'on a lu cette semaine son père
et enfin j'espère pas son père en tout
cas potentiellement oui sans
attendre et ce dès sur tous et c'est
illégal s'est lui dit que elle elle
consentait mais ça veut dire que même
les met ses discussions avec son avocat
concernant la tutelle et concernant le
conflit éclair il les écoute est donc
c'est tout bonnement scandaleux bien s'y
attendait un peu inquiet pour la
personnellement depuis un an mais
pourquoi on n'avait
pas mettre une photo sur instagram
évidemment on est un poil non mais même
si c'est un lanceur de choses et oui
mais quand et comment on peut juger de
son état psychologique à verser
4 photos à poil et une tutelle
même on le voit elle semble pas tu perds
ton bébé ce qui était déjà je pense un
pour moi très dangereux pour elle de
mener cette grossesse à terme tu perds
ton bébé deux jours après tu te roule
dans le sac par terre en tenant tessin
tu vois bien qu'à un moment ses faits et
gestes ne démontre pas qu'elle est
totalement équilibrée
le père de beyoncé s'apprête à tout
révéler sur la superstar dans un biopic
ll est fâché avec son père visiblement
elle est pas contente de ça alors est ce
que ça vous choque ou pas cela ne choque
mais je suis outré c'est un sale type
mathieu noir mathew knowles comment vous
dire ça fait quelques années qu'il a
commencé une campagne un peu pour
dénigrer sa fille en disant qu' elle un
succès planétaire c'est parce qu'elle a
la peau claire et aux états unis les
light skins et les dark skin ya un petit
peu une petite guéguerre déjà il dit ça
il dit que bien s'est il va cracher sur
sur ses plus grosses fêlures le fait
qu'elle sache pas trop s'exprimer en
public ils racontent plein de
d'atrocités concernant beyoncé qui lui
en veut par rapport à auffay qu'elle est
qu'il ait mis la main dans la caisse
comme le père de whitney houston à
l'époque c'est pour ça qu'ils se sont
séparés c'est parce qu'il lui a volé de
l'oseille en fait de lui ce qu'il dit
aussi cbd que sans lui mais c'est elle
ne serait pas du lycée et qui sait le
donnait à bout berman et qu'aujourd'hui
mais récolte pas les fruits n'est que
avec elle n'est pas généreux les noms
comme joe jackson comme tous ceux qui
ont fait des enfants stars mais il il a
volé de jean et ils sortent jusqu'à
maintenant sur le succès de beyoncé de
solange qu'est-ce qui vient de casser
les burnes
[Musique]
madonna a fait cette vidéo choc mois sur
toutes nos qui est depuis sa fille
lourdès a dit voilà ce qui se passe
quand et sous percocet c'est une façon
détournée d'un sujet que madonna
instable agi de manière erratique et a
tardé suite à la prise d'eau pias et
donc de drogue les internautes la
rejoignent et demande presque que les
autorités interviennent pour vous
occuper de madonna parce qu'elle est la
lâcher complètement complètement sur la
vidéo alors bien c'est bien évidemment
elle est gonflée par le botox elle est
figée par l'acide hyaluronique celle
inverse d'ailleurs mais peu importe mais
on voit que dans ses yeux il ya une
substance ya l'alcool ll doit très mal
vieilli
relaxer un peu on sent un peu que c'est
une sorte de d'échappatoire elle va sur
tic comme sont pas des petites vidéos
après le regrette le lendemain les
efface
ya la maison de justin bieber maisons
coloniales date et datant des années 30
et la payer 8 million et demi c'est
celle-là de dollars bof mais moi joli
mais perd jolie parlons harnais konon
une blague elle est magnifique alors
maintenant madonna la maison de madonna
we madonna telle collection céline dion
alors là on ne donnerait la vulgarité
et voilà les travaux qu'elle a fait elle
a fait 15 millions de dollars de travaux
pour qu'ils aient cette espèce de deux
toboggans immonde pour sedan aquatique
oui on aime beaucoup mais pas beaucoup
de goût d'acheter à bas dicaprio voilà
il s'est offert une villa estimée à 7
millions de dollars
non c'est dans le quartier de los feliz
a los angeles c'est joli oui mais il est
du coup ce garçon efféminé ses plus
petits lacets menant à
acculer mois
ah bah voilà plus de 1000 m abbas et la
camair
voilà
alors ils ont vécu là avec vanessa
paradis elle est bien à vendre pour 23
millions de dollars en 2016 mais ils ont
toujours pas réussi à se débarrasser s'y
intéresse quelqu'un la dernière je vais
vous dire la dernière à votre avis à qui
appartient à garder une salle de bain
c'est difficile donc c'est quelqu'un qui
pas où est ce que vous avez eu toutes
ces photos c'est magnifique
alors c'est un peu rococo c'est un peu
kasserine ça les séries ou sans cesse en
normandie ce papier c'est la maison
leroux qui assainira pardon mais
les photos sur internet
qu'on a violé